hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday [__] it January 22nd
2024 what's going on how are
you yeah but I'm out in my [__] gay
rage out here and my [__] TV first of
all has been [__] up for like a
year you know I never get around to
calling the [__] guy cuz I don't want
to I just don't want to deal with it so
now here it is there's a playoff playoff
playoff game right now is happening the
Lions against Tampa Bay Buccaneers 17-10
it's great [__] game okay Lions had
the
momentum all right Buccaneers come back
tie it up at the half lions are now up
by seven [__] pass interference call
here come the bucks
right go out to my [__] garage and oh
my God the cable actually works but you
know what's [__] hilarious the only
Channel that's coming in I swear to God
is the QVC Channel channel on up like I
can't even get network [__] TV on
this thing I
literally was just hopping
mad screaming are you [__] kidding
me I was so livid I had to hit mute cuz
I couldn't listen to this Larry Hagman
looking [__] talking about this
[__] pot like he was actually excited
about it next to this other woman so
that's where I'm at so I don't know
what's going on with the playoffs I did
watch
uh as much as I could of yesterday's
games
um I had the Ravens and I had the 49ers
to cover both lay in N9 and a half and
uh you know Texans returned a kick or
something like that I think it was a
kick and for a second it was close and
then they just kind of ran away with it
I will say though I I I don't
like how much Lamar Jackson has to run
all the time
I just kind of feel like
that style of play at the pro
level you only do that for so long I
always look at Michael Vic who was with
one other than like maybe Dion Sanders
or Bo Jackson was the fastest guy I ever
saw and they even caught up to him at
one
point and he got hurt so that's the only
thing that I would worry about other
than that their defense looked great
everything was was uh great about that
and then
um Green Bay who I was less than
impressed in the second half of Dallas
shows you what the [__] I know came out
and gave San Francisco 49ers all they
could handle all they could handle thank
God [__] uh uh Pete pasty face there
missed that [__] field
goal
um or the 49ers I mean they they would
have been playing play for uh for
overtime um was amazing when he missed
that field goal you just knew the 49ers
or just just NFL football it's like oh
now they go down the field and then they
score the touch like every [__] time
every [__] time there's an
amazing come from behind [__] win in
all of these games it's just like they
used to had this thing when I was a kid
they used to used to be called uh Alcoa
present fantastic finishes and they
would have to go back years to somebody
throw a touchdown the last second the
[__] game it happens every weekend
now um which I think is by Design
through rule changes and all of that
[__] and these stupid ass [__]
defensive schemes so um you know my
money was on the 49ers but watching how
Green Bay was playing and
everything I was
like now I want these guys to win and I
hope I hope the 49ers aren't going to
squeak out of a victory here and that's
what they did they went down and
squeaked it out and now 49ers fans of
course are acting like they dominated
the [__] game not real 49er fans you
know real 49er fans would say you know
Green Bay is [__] good team and gave
him every but just the loud ones on
Instagram maybe they're Bots I don't
know what they are um so but those were
two great games the Detroit Buccaneer
game looked great I got to knock this
out cuz my kids are napping right now
and I'm going to watch that Bill's uh
Chiefs
game so uh I took Tampa getting the
points and then I got I got the
Chiefs and uh the only reason I'm it's
weird like I'm taking the Chiefs but I'm
rooting for the bills cuz I want to see
them finally push through but like I'm
doing the anything better podcast so I
have to say how I I I'm betting you know
but
um I believe in the Chiefs in the
playoffs until they [__] the bed cuz
those [__] guys every year you know
fumbling bumbling stumbling through the
regular season and then the playoff come
around and they just seem to lock it
down
uh oh my
God the bills have to do it I mean
they're like they're like the they're
like the afc's like
Cowboys
um at this point minus any Super Bowl
championships I think they won an AFL
title like way back in the day um way
well way way way back in the day um
anyway speaking of that uh what did I do
this week I uh I caught a cold sort of
I've been like fighting it off there's
something going around with all the kids
so then they come home and they end up
giving it to you my son has been getting
up like clockwork at
3:35 in the
morning to the point we like lock the
door hoping he'll get frustrated and he
just like he just sits there like you
know like
knocking like
[Music]
3:35 then you just hear him breathing
through the door
like and then you just
hear
hello just like oh my God buddy go to
bed what are you
doing you
know and uh he's potty trained and
everything but he still wears a diaper
to bed so he'll get up and be like dad
die wet I
wet my God Jesus Christ so then I get up
right point my toes at my knees so I
don't [__] snap my achilles that's a
good one for old guys Point your toes at
your knees for like a good 15 20 seconds
point it the other way if you start to
get any sort of Charlie horse in your
legs just go the opposite way
um that immediately releases it rather
than making all those noises and waking
up your wife so I end up uh
uh you know changing him or whatever and
then he's asking me to sleep in his bed
with him and I'm like no budy you have
to stay here so I go to close the door
he starts whining which're just going to
wake up everybody in the house so I say
okay fine so he his bedroom was also the
guest room so there's like an
adult-sized bed that he sleeps in so I
[__] get on the other side of it so
it's me and him so there's plenty of
room so what does he do he gets on me
like a freaking
koala what is it eucalyptus is that what
they're always on right and he's just
like kicking me and doing all this [__]
until 5:15 in the
morning breathing in my ear playing with
my beard and I'm just laying there like
you got to be [__] kidding me
um and then we both kind of nod off and
I wake
up around like 7:30
8 and I can hear him like he's asleep
but he's also his head head is still on
me and I look over at him it's like
mouth is open he looks adorable right
and I'm like
like passed out and of course the second
I move and then he's up Dad I want
pancakes dad I can I have
[Laughter]
pancakes so
um anyway but I I Shield my lovely wife
from that because like you got you kind
of got to figure out what people are
good at my wife is not good at waking up
in the middle of the night and handling
[__] and then going back to bed it makes
her super she makes her almost as grumpy
as I am after eight hours sleep I'm
working on it um so I always take the
bullet I'm like I I'll do that but she
handles
uh she handles all that Mom [__] you
know like knowing what's going on at
school what a events packing their
lunches and doing all of that [__] I'm
more like to [__] clean up the mess
get the shoes on guy [__]
um but
anyway um I've continued to go out this
week uh doing standup putting together
like this next 20 minutes really excited
about that still playing the drums and I
have not been able to fly cuz this is
the time of year where it like [__]
rains every day for like I don't know
two weeks and that's our rain for the
year so I just got to kind of ride this
out which is [__] hilarious cuz right
when I my tour
starts all right is when it's going to
stop [__] raining and then that you
know it's just always like that I
actually there's a few like things I
want to go
fly to see
um you know there's there uh this
Rockstar's house that you can take a uh
a tour of not going to say who there's
too many you know weirdos out there well
how the [__] would they know when I was
all right Johnny Cash's house you can
take take a tour of one of his houses in
ohigh um so I was thinking of flying up
that way with a buddy of mine and then
just cruising up and checking it out cuz
they like you got to see it man they
like redid the
house um like the way that he had it and
uh I'm not going to lie it kind of
looked perfect you know what is Dean Del
re got me into that midcentury
architecture I used to always just call
it Brady Bunch architecture like I was
never into that [__] and now of a sudden
I'm I'm getting like [__] obsessed
with it it always just looked like weird
to me because we always grew up in like
you know old
houses or whatever being on like the
East Coast you know those ones they'd
have like a
[__] they'd have those old heating
systems from the early 1900s and you
either felt like you were in a sauna or
you could see your
breath depending on how close you were
cuz the heat was [__] no joke you
just couldn't shut it off like you shut
it off and within eight [__]
minutes um yeah for the mo the I I moved
around a lot as a kid but the the main
house that I lived in was we lived in a
duplex and there was a family in the
back of the house and then we had the
front of the house and it was this big
old turn of the century house with this
incredible wood and all of that and you
know what's funny was when I grew up I
always was thinking like someday I'm
going to buy this house off of the
landlord and open it back
up because I thought it was so cool cuz
it had two
staircases it's like from back in those
days when you had like a
staff you know and it was so funny like
they would always have like the front
staircase that the owners of the house
had would be this really decorative wood
and all of that and then in the back of
the house would be just like a basic
staircase for the air quote help
whatever the [__] they used to say about
back then to come up and they would be
downstairs making your breakfast and
then when you came downstairs they would
go up the back of the stairs to make up
the beds and all of that and the whole
thing was that you didn't want to see
them can you imagine treating people
like that they made you [__]
breakfast you don't even say thanks and
it's like we have an Our Own Private
staircase cuz we don't want to see you
and then yeah clean up my [__] uh
soiled sheets or whatever I mean it's
just [__] it's unreal um but I didn't
know that as a kid I just thought it was
so [__] cool cuz everybody else that
I hung out with had a newer house so
there was just one you know staircase
going up and coming back down I always
thought it was cool that there was
two
um and it had all these weird windows
and all of that type of [__] and
uh you know I always wonder what
happened in that [__] house um anyway
oh Billy going down memory lane here
going down memory lane and I've been
doing that a lot I've come out of my
[__] depression I realized what it
was is I need to do stand up more
because it makes me so [__] happy and
I get a rush and I can stay ahead of the
fog there and
um I mean I I was I was in a bad place
like there was something about David
Soul dying who played hutch on stari and
Hutch like I remember when that show
came out and watching him [__]
jumping over the car and sliding across
the [__] Hood I'm like how the [__]
is that guy dead Andy's
80 you know rest his soul Jesus Christ
um he's also I think Magnum Force um
with Clint
Eastwood and um I it just I went down
you know like they call like death
scrolling or whatever on Instagram I
went on like a death scroll and I just
started to see who the [__] was still
alive from all of these shows and I had
to stop at lever and
Shirley you know happy days isn't that
bad the older people and the one who
played Joanie unfortunately are gone but
I went to [__] leverne and Shirley
everybody on the show is dead except for
Michael mcken who played Lenny they're
all gone I didn't even know Shirley
died she died last year rester s and I
was just going like what the [__] but I
ended on a happier note with taxi where
most people are still alive and I was
just like what am I doing
like what is the purpose of this [__]
exercise cuz I'm I've been a person who
has not given a [__] about his
age and uh somewhere sometime during I
don't know if it's being 55 or if I just
took too much time off the road and I
was just like I'm not going to drink a
bunch of coffee I'm not smoking cigars
and I just
[__] just sat
here and it all just sort of [__] the
walls started closing in
so fortunately I'm lucky enough to love
my job so uh I've been going out doing
that and that has been uh you know going
down there and shooting the [__] with
other Comedians and stuff just doing
that it it it definitely pulls me out of
it but
um I don't know it is that is kind of a
weird thing so anyway uh I don't know
what I'm going to do on this podcast
should I just like stop here and watch
the rest of these [__] you guys don't
need my analogies right you're going to
see you're going to see what
happens
um all right so the top drum songs that
I'm listening to right now that I've
been trying to play along
to um I told you was Jackson 5 dancing
machine that has James Gadson on
it and those hits are on that dancing
dancing she's a dancing one two three
four so the first hit is on Two And the
second hit is on the and of three and it
is [__] awkward is
[__] um cuz they just come in they don't
count it off or anything they just go
right in and I'm telling you I know I
talked about this the other day if you
play drums you have to listen to James
gadson's drum track it's a it's a
masterpiece
um and then I've been listening to uh
continue with James
Gadson uh with Bill Withers uh use me in
uh what that song When I'm kissing my
love and then uh oh I already talked
about
this what was that one that three dog
night Mama Told Me Not to
Come I've been listening to that and
then I was in the lovely Nia's car and
she likes all you know it's funny she
likes listening to that [__] yach
rock [__] which is so funny that they
call it yach Rock like that was like it
was called singer
songwriter music in the 70s when that
first came out then it was kind of
called easy listening and then what
happened was the Baby Boomers the ones
that became like [__] the sociopaths
that just
descended to the heights of their
business and just took took took took
took right never bought into that Summer
of Love [__] you know then they got you
know big boats and [__] and they would
be listening to this [__] that they
listen to as kids but it's funny that
it's now called yach Rock and people
think that like people actually were
writing songs about the sea on purpose
for people with Yachts or what whatever
that it got renamed that it was like the
Laurel Canyon scene singer songwriter
thing um like the Eagles have nothing to
do with Yachts like I don't even they
don't sing about Yachts or anything like
that I don't you know it just they just
labeled it that to sell this to older
Boomers and I always called it like when
I listen to those songs to me it's
station wagon music because I would
always be riding in the car with my mom
and she would be listening to you know
diamond girl or like the Little River
Band you know Glenn
Campbell the Eagles all of those [__]
like all the cool moms in the 70s you
know and they had their scarf you know
tied over their head with the curlers
and they would be driving down the
street my mom didn't smoke but I used to
see the other ones they had those skinny
cigarettes you know it was sort of the
cuse light of cancer you know you had
that little skinny [__] cigarette you
know they had the window cracked and
they would be smoking that thing and it
was all Earth Tones and they would be
driving like these PE green [__]
station wagons with a matching dashboard
and then like a brown interior it was
[__] amazing I remember like the the
people across the street had one of
those great
uh like one of the last Woodies I think
they had the uh what the [__] was that
was almost look like a Ford Galaxy the
front end but it was a station wagon
with like the [__] wood and then
their dad was this big CEO guy and every
two years he' get a new company card and
was always like it was always a Lincoln
Continental and
uh he would come pulling up in that big
he was a big dude got out of the car
just the [__] guys guy there was some
cool cars in my this is when I was
really young back in like the early 70s
I knew there was this kid
um kind of a troubled kid but I remember
he was a little bit older than us he's
one used to come over and like beat the
[__] out of me and break my toys and
stuff you know I told you that story
right my my mom got me a little cowboy
outfit for my
birthday and I went outside I had a
little holer and it was supposed to be
like mother of pearl like handles on the
guns the like cap guns and they wer L
really plastic you know and I had a
little bandana little cowboy hat a
little vest and I went outside by myself
I walked to the end of the driveway and
him and his friends were walking by and
they just grabbed the guns out of my
holster and just smashed them on the
ground and walked
away it was so F when I think about it
it was so [__] that's where all like
those effis for family stories came from
I remember one time climbing a tree with
a friend of mine and we were up there
and those same kids came walking by and
we were trying to keep quiet and they
saw us up there there and they basically
just threw rocks at us until we cried
and then they got bored and they
[Laughter]
left we used to throw snowballs at cars
and every once in a while some type a
[__] lunatic would get out and would
just not stop chasing you till he caught
one of
you
um yeah there was a lot of
like yeah big kids beat eating the [__]
out of you and there was a lot of really
angry adults we were always [__] with
their cars throwing rotten apples in
them or sticking him in the tailpipe and
[__] like that I see you guys I see you
up there these [__] lunatics um
anyway but
uh this is what happens dude when your
[__] TV doesn't work I was supposed
to be coming out here watching the God
damn
game and uh you know H what are you
going to do um anyway Let's uh let's do
the reads for this week and then I'm you
know what I'm going to do I'm going to
watch that Buffalo game maybe I'll come
on at the [__] end here uh you know
what I'm not going to do the [__]
reads I'm just going to go into your
questions [__] the advertising here uh
Monday morning content uh used to think
people were
smug oh this is
interesting I like this you used to
think people were smug please tell me
you you had you found a more positive
way of looking at it dear Bill I'd like
to Piggy back off the guy from a few
weeks ago few weeks back who said he
realized he's the [__] and lost so
many
friends I'm trying to remember that guy
I've been playing these brain
games on Instagram that's supposed to
help with your
memory so there they're [__] weird
it's like you have your hands closed you
open your hands one of your one of your
hands has two fingers the other one has
one then you close them again and then
you switch the other one has two the
other one has one it's supposed to like
help you
brain so I remember hearing a long time
ago that playing drums was actually good
for your brain like learning like
Independence I don't think just once you
get it down and if you just keep playing
within your
uh well maybe that's something if you
just stay within yourself like you know
I'm reading at this level I know this
amount of that another language or I
know this amount of guitar whatever you
keep pushing yourself maybe that's a
good thing I don't know I don't want to
get that [__] I've had some of that um
with some relatives man that's [__]
scary
anyway um so this person said uh I used
to think people were smug when they just
looked back at me during a conflict then
I realized it usually happens when I'm
angry and not listening to them and
giving off the energy that I would never
even consider what they're
[Laughter]
saying oh my god do I relate to that
yeah they're just waiting for you to
finish so they can walk away they're
actually just being polite at that point
uh this part you can probably relate to
yes ding ding ding ding ding uh well not
long ago I had some guy going off on me
about something and I just looked back
at him and didn't take the bait cuz
honestly it caught me off guard and I
also didn't care as much as he did about
it so a minute into his tiate he called
me a smug
[__] yeah at that point he's trying to
get a reaction
I have to say man like is there anything
more embarrassing than fighting like a
one-way War and the other person like
that was like there's this [__] La
guy it was so goddamn funny he went to
New York and he tried to order a
gluten-free scooped out bagel with some
something or
whatever and everybody was telling him
to and he goes I I said that and they
all just told me to [__] off and get the
[__] out of that Deli and then he just
goes all right
on to the next
one and all these New Yorkers were like
proud about how [__] angry they are
and they were getting angry at this guy
about his stupid [__] bagel order and
it's just like dude what are you really
mad at why do you you didn't know that
this guy was doing that and the guy at
the first Deli could just say listen we
don't do that like I don't know what
that is good luck to you welcome to New
York but everyone is like
um New Yorkers Boston like everybody's
in love with you got to keep your Edge
like you know you got to make sure
you're not happy you got to be rude you
know what I like about New York people
tell you to go [__]
yourself you know where you I love this
one you know where you stand with people
on the East Coast no you
don't there's just as many slick lion
pieces of [__] back there as there are
out here and I've lived in both places
so I don't want to [__] hear it
um anyway
um so anyway the guy so I minute in my
Chate he calls me a smug [__] I was
thinking hey that's my line then it all
came together those people weren't smug
they were just more balanced people
anyways off to
therapy all right I know I interrupted
with my own stories but there there was
a lot of
wisdom and all of that that's uh what
this person's going for uh I hope
happens to me and I I I hope that for
all of you guys where you can kind
of you know after all you know if
something's not working it's pretty
amazing one day when you realize how
you're contributing to it or why you're
doing it or just some little piece of
information that can help you make like
a a change but
um it's [__] hard man it's really
it's really hard like me jumping I'm 55
jumping up and down upset that my TV
that hasn't worked for a year and I've
done nothing about it to fix
it and I'm
screaming really flipping the [__] out
when a year ago I could have called the
[__] cable guy and he could have came
in and just fix the [__]
thing I just don't do it I just I
I I
um I flip out and then I just move on to
the next thing stupid not a bright guy
guys okay just just know that know that
if you haven't figured it out yet all
right I mean I'm you know I walk into a
bar I'm pretty smart for a bar that's
another thing too there's a lot of
people out there that think they're
smart but it's like no you're just kind
of hanging out with
idiots you know you're smart for an
idiot but you know when people like a
lot of people think they're [__]
smart it's like you know there's people
out there that like are
solving massive massive
problems and healthc Care
engineering Aviation just
like half this [__] that I'm using right
now the microphone all of this I don't
know how the [__] this [__] works I I
don't know how to design this I can't
imagine the brain power how smart you
have to be and the things that you have
to understand about the [__]
Universe um
anyway then you know what's funny is you
meet those people you know you have a
buddy of mine he goes yeah this guy he's
he's so smart he can't comb his hair
those people are like so in their head
like thinking Brainiac [__] when they
look in the mirror they they don't even
see
themselves you
know and when you think about some of
the greatest scientists ever they they
all have like Bed Head like I don't know
like you're so busy
like
thinking it must have been a you know
it's kind of funny I when did scientists
stop getting [__] cuz back in the day
like they were like famous you used to
get at least the white person did you'd
get
credit for inventing things you know
anybody not white they just you know it
it kind of didn't pan out that way
um it's
just um and now nobody gets Credit Now
nobody like nobody knows who invented
anything anymore there's all these crazy
inventions every [__] year and it's
just apples got a new [__] well who
did
it what is the person's name I want to
know who who's the Eli Whitney who's the
[__]
uh you know Johnny apples seed I can't
even name scientist who else invented
things
Tesla and then that other grumpy [__]
took all the all the credit right Edison
Thomas
Edison he was sort of like the original
Jim
ERS all right
Epstein Billy kronite here's why the
Epstein list is crazy and it worth worth
at least an inkling of
attention the list is a flight log that
was confiscated when he was arrested
yeah here's my qu according to
who files were sealed due to the nature
of the investigation I.E it involved
rich people not average
civilians how about also that it was an
island and the there's there's no
jurisdiction that anybody really has he
would have had to been doing this [__]
in the United States he had like his own
country um Este Epstein was arrested
based on the accounts of several females
who were held against their will in a
sex ring how he got his money and
influence is a whole story you might be
interested to check out um I'm not
interested and I don't buy that list for
a [__] minute I just I just don't it
like it's like 2 years [__] later all
of those people are like super [__]
powerful first of all nothing's going to
[__] happen and what I love is nobody
gives a [__] about those
women what they really want to see is a
famous politician or some celebrity lose
their house and go to jail and all of
that so they can watch somebody go down
but they they they're not going to be
like hey we've created a home for all of
those poor 12year olds that were getting
banged by these
CEOs right and politicians they're not
going to do anything for them that's why
I don't
like the story CU it's not about helping
anybody it's you know it's immediately
politicized Trump went there Bill
Clinton went there it comes red becomes
red and blue like everything else that's
why I I kind of avoided it but you know
what you know what I'll have an open
mind here anyway even before the events
on the island became public he was
initially arrested and prosecuted for
unlawful sex with a minor a number of
girls around the age of 14 testified to
hanging out at a mansion and being
exploited the evidence was damning and
anyone else would have gone to prison
for life instead he got out even after
this he was still courting Millionaires
and politicians and constantly F flying
to his private island where the
nefarious acts took
place um that's alleged buddy just cuz
you went to his [__] Island didn't
mean you partook cing anything you could
just be going there kissing this guy's
ass hoping he would give you money for
for the campaign I thought that there's
also that part too um it wasn't until
recently that the court released certain
files under the Freedom of Information
Act oh I love that the Freedom of
Information Act you know the one that
they were going to let you know we're
going to finally figure out what
happened with the Warren
Commission those things when they when
they release them in like half of it is
blacked
out that's not Freedom of Information
they're still censoring it I I find the
whole
thing
highly Highly Questionable um that there
was this list and that these people that
were on the list were so [__] afraid
of their name getting out and what was
going to happen that they had to kill
Epstein and then they kill him and then
a list still comes out so like what was
the [__]
point you know that was basically my bit
when they killed Oswald like the list
didn't come out it was it he was dead
and they were like he did it and then
they had the Warren Commission yep he
did in fact do it and it was done there
was no oh by the way uh the CIA or the
Cubans or the Russians there was none of
that there none of that the mob um it
was over anyway of all things that
occasionally make it into the news this
is something that actually matters since
he was allegedly blackmailing us
politicians
okay all right well I know this is this
list is exciting but can I ask you a
question what exactly has
happened since the list has come out all
it is is just a bunch of regular people
saying who they think was on the list or
who is on the list who isn't on the list
none of these guys are going to get
prosecuted it's just it's just going to
fade
away um there are lots of independent
journalists who have documented the case
and tied him to several intelligent
agencies most notably the arresting
officers in Florida were told to back
off from long-term investigations by
intelligent officials who took over the
case um yeah I mean this all tracks this
sounds like the typical Above the
Law um white person with his own Island
I mean this
is Hollywood has been making movies
about people like this forever right
doesn't James Bond come over there and
the guy's petting a cat um considering
young women were raped You' think the
behavior you think to believe all women
crowd and media would have helped
amplify the
issue um Clinton was on his plane 48
times after his initial
arrest sometimes without Secret Service
oh yeah I
mean I mean I wouldn't doubt that Bill
Gates was too and his wife cited their
friendship as an issue in divorce
proceedings and as a consolation I'll
mention Stephen Hawking was as well who
according to records was into midgets
and
threesoms I mean all
right this is can I be honest with you
dude this is all just a bunch of hearsay
and what I love about all of this is all
you're naming is famous people like this
and and that's all people care about is
Clinton Bill Gates stepen Hawkin what
about all those other guys we like who's
that guy [__] that guy I don't know who
that guy is I don't know who that guy is
so that's not exciting that's not an
exciting story let's go after this guy
let me tell nothing's going to happen to
any of those [__] people and no one's
going to help those women and there's
going to be another [__] [__] with
an island and they'll continue to do
that [__] because those people are
literally above the law and when you're
above the law you can also control the
[__] list or control whatever happens
to the people on the list and I'll tell
you who's not going to report or do a
[__] thing about it unless they pick
a political side will be any major News
Network 24-hour News Network they're not
going to do anything about it so I don't
know what all the excitement about the
list is like somebody's going to go go
down and get punished or the big thing
maybe they're going to help uh those
poor girls that were on the [__]
Island um when that happens I will get
excited by that story but other than
that it's just a bunch of chasing your
tail [__] I think anyway anyways of
all the things people talk about I think
this is better than a lot of news
covered cuz these people control the
Food Supplies as you say almost
literally in Bill Gates case I wish to
prevent defense was mentioned in the
case so you would have read about the
details love you Bill thanks for the
laughs um okay I mean fair enough but
you know so you read about the details
and let me ask you this so what's going
to happen now that you're so
informed okay cuz I've gone
down if you listen to my podcast from
about 10 12 years ago I was air quote
informed I wasn't I just didn't trust
anybody and I was just reading all of
this conspiracy theory and and that's
what I was doing and guess what happened
nothing nothing it just stayed the
course it just continues in the
direction it's going in whether there's
a Democrat or
Republican um
spokesperson
so you
know and I have to be honest with you
there there wasn't too much information
that you you put you threw in
there that I didn't already hear about
so I I don't
know
you know I don't know I just okay you
know okay oh dude the list is coming
out oh [__] man there's a
list oh Bill Clinton's shaking in his
boot he isn't he
isn't he isn't nothing's going to happen
nothing's going to happen that's it
what's going to happen is there's going
to be a bunch of people talking about it
on Reddit and then that's that's that's
going to be the extent of it
um you know and that's to be honest with
you is why I stopped watching the news
you know to sit there and watch two
presidential elections in the row where
the Democratic party which I don't even
relate to anymore you know we elect who
we want to run for president and they
say no [__] you and now they're telling
people you know they can't be on the
ballot and that they're you know they're
boxing people out they're calling people
Communists and anti-semites and all of
this [__] and um which is fine okay
let's just say that they're right about
all those C but the things that they're
talking about you know they're not
reporting you know I don't think it's
good that a corporation is going to try
to buy up all of the houses they
possibly can in this
country
um I don't know why that's not being
reported on and uh you know but they
don't they just keep it like all they
talk about is [__] taxes securing the
border and just [__] to get people all
[__] riled up I will say something
that's [__] hilarious is the amount
of people that [__] on California and
talk oh everybody's leaving that [__]
[__] hole of a state uh you know if
you're a republican your boy Donald
Trump [__] buried the state he also
buried New York he created all of these
new taxes in this baby temper tantrum
that he had because we didn't vote for
him and that's why the taxes are so
[__] high not because of liberals or
anything like that that [__] [__]
buried us
and here's the thing once taxes are put
in place they never go off the books
ever um a Democrat or Republican is not
going to take him off the books so
enough with that [__] uh birthday
weekends for the ladies hey Billy F250
wanted to get your thoughts on this so
I'm a 51-year-old father of
four work full-time wife works
part-time uh I recently had a birthday
prior to my birthday I had a
conversation with my wife and
18-year-old daughter generally my
birthday presents are [__] because I'm a
dad and I get it that's
fine I know you just have to accept it
like the kids get awesome gifts your
wife has to get awesome gifts and uh you
know you're just a guy um anyways for
this particular birthday I wanted a new
tennis racket I'm a 3.5 rating I don't
know what that means which for people
that play tennis understand where that
ranks which is somewhat competitive on
an amateur level at 51 that's amazing
you're
running Baseline to Baseline is that
what they call it uh knowing that my
wife wouldn't know which racket I would
want I thought I would buy it for myself
and they wouldn't have to worry about
getting me anything my my conversation
with my daughter happened to be at the
kitchen table too and the wife went like
this so have you guys got me anything
from my birthday yet because I have an
idea on what I wanted and was thinking I
would buy it for
myself the response was of course how
much is it I said it's around 250 bucks
they both immediately gasped and
said you can just get one uh at Target
or big can't you just get one at Target
a big five uh took the high road I very
calmly explained that I wanted a higher
end racket since I play a couple times a
week and have improved my
game uh it was left that my wife would
think about
it now keep in mind for my wife and
daughter they don't have birthdays they
have birthday weekends which consist of
multiple days weekend getaways dinner
with different family and friends this
is
even this is even if their birthday is
on a
Wednesday oh my God
these stories
dude these sto It's [__] amazing I
like I hear these stories and I hear
this [__] a lot and and like uh I'm
lucky my wife is is cool as [__] she's
the reason I have my old truck when I
finally saw that thing oh my God I love
that thing she goes just buy it and I
was like really she's like yeah go buy
it go buy it you know she she's never
been
like she's never been like that um and
I've always been like you know what do
you want for your birthday I always go
nothing don't get me anything I don't
need anything I want like an experience
or whatever so occasionally there is
something that uh that I do want so I I
kind of lucked out I feel bad for this
guy Jesus Christ as I left the
conversation and left let my wife think
about it I was pretty steamed that it
was even questioned considering I don't
ask for much pretty much pay for
everything mortgage electricity cable
groceries
yeah you know instead of being steamed
the thing that works with women just say
like you know calmly go for a walk and
have your Tourette's as you walk around
or jump up and down and yell at your TV
in your garage like me and then go back
in and what really works with women is
calm
energy uh guess how I figured this
out calm
energy and just saying listen
um I know you guys didn't do this on
purpose so don't come at them accusatory
so they can hear what you're saying and
just say listen that really hurt my
feelings
um I feel like you know I was telling
you guys what I wanted for my
birthday and you guys were telling me to
get the cheaper version you weren't I
didn't feel heard and then I feel like
let me finish let me just let me just
say this because they're going to
interrupt by then and then just say like
you know I look forward to when it's
your birthdays and we do birthday
weekends for you guys and I love all the
different events and everything and I
feel like I'm not asking for a weekend
I'm just asking for a tennis racket I
didn't feel that that was too big of an
ask but you guys made me feel like I was
being
selfish there you go you just do
that or you can do what you're going to
do which is just go out and buy the
[__]
racket this is what you should there's
the other way you can do it if you just
want to be like [__] passive
aggressive and
hostile go to the party store whatever
the [__] they call buy yourself a
birthday hat one of those New Year
[__] things put the Hat on no don't
take buy buy one of those little [__]
stupid hats and that noise maker then go
bu your Racket and then walk into your
house have it on unzip it show it to
them and then blow the horn and then
just [__] walk
away
happy birthday to
me um that's one way you could do it
person says I'll pay 250 bucks on a
family birthday dinner with the
in-laws and all that is a shitty memory
with people you see too much anyway uh
but like I said I took the high road and
didn't pick an argument very wise about
an hour later my wife came back and said
you know what you should get the racket
my daughter strongly agreed as well wow
okay so bottom line like you talk about
often you got to pick your battles with
these women well you know the big thing
was that you didn't go like I'm [__]
pay for everything you fun grateful
[__] that would have been that would
have been the end of it um huge fan of
what of all you do thank you in my
opinion paper tiger is the best standup
special ever well I would not agree with
that but that is very that very nice
thanks for reading and go [__] yourself
which you should probably say well Bill
what do you think is is the greatest
standup special of all time mine is
Richard prior live in concert the one he
did down in Long Beach and then if I was
going to say the greatest ones of all
time
um H those are
tough Dave Chappelle Killing Them
Softly um not only did I love that
hour I loved uh what he was doing and
what he was saying versus what everyone
else was doing and saying at the time I
thought it was absolutely brilliant not
you know not that I don't love all his
other specials that was the one that was
sort of the first
one um that I feel created his Legend
like this guy is above and
beyond um other Comics um I would say
yay yay
yay Eddie Murphy
Raw the George Carlin one where he
uh was talking about the Earth just
shaking us off that bit about AIDS was
[__]
amazing
um H that's a tough
one trying to I would say Steve
Martin um had one in the late '70s that
was
amazing and once again that was one of
those ones compared to what people were
talking about you know everyone was so
[__] serious and wearing these you
know Vietnam Army coats from when they
served or something that they bought in
protest to mock the government
everything was really [__] serious
and then he came out and was just
[__] falling on the ground funny like
silly um which is was was really
needed it was amazing like that time CU
like um the way the music industry had
just sort of jumped
on
um you know black music and kind of sort
of turned it into like disco and they
just sort
of you know it was right around Disco
Duck I swear to God was a song Disco
Duck like that's how big disco just put
that you know high hat opening and
closing
every [__] song that they you know
what Donald Duck sounded this duck was
singing about going out to the Disco and
it was disco disco duck and then oh it
was really it was really bad um and
right around that time as far as White
Rock music Van Halen one came out and it
was just like this lightning
bolt that just cut through all of this
[__] and it was fun it was loud it was
aggressive it was just
[__] it was really really like in a
lot of ways I feel like it was sort of
the the beetle Mania of La which I know
they've done documentaries about that
but like the
[__] guitar Shredder scene out
here you know I've talked to that uh
Dave Kushner who did the uh the music on
FIS for family was talking about like
how how many people could just [__]
shred out
here
um like at one point in garages all
around
La was like the Van Halen's [__]
Randy rhods like
uh that was that D Martini guy from rat
and all of them it's just everybody was
just [__] slash was somewhere
shredding um
and I feel like Van Halen breaking
through was like a a a huge thing for
the scene out here um anyway getting off
track here let's let's read the next
thing that is going on here what's
what's where am I here all right brother
is a
swinger oh my god well how the [__] did
you have this com Billy
binski wait a minute how do you know
your brother is a swinger and are you
married there's no [__] way he
approached you and your
wife you know what's funny about like
lately there's you know I was telling
you Dean got me into all this you know
uh architecture and [__] so I've been
following these different
accounts on Instagram and uh there was
something you should look this up uh a
conversation
pit so they they're [__] cool as hell
they they were like in the middle of a a
living room they would like dig like
this hole and they and like probably
like I don't know like four 5T deep and
then they would just around the hole
three4 the way around like an old school
football stadium like a horseshoe they
would put a couch and then you had
little stairs to go into and the
conversation pit was you would go down
into it and you guys have would have
conversations man and it just reeks of
like Boogie Nights drug abuse and then
like swinging like back in the day they
would have like these swinger parties
and they would have like a giant ashtray
and everyone would just throw their keys
in and whatever Keys you pulled out was
like who you [__] hooked up with I
imagine women on one probably two
ashtrays Jesus Christ we never know out
here
um that's kind of what I just think I
just think everybody just all [__]
hairy it's just crazy um gross all right
Billy binsky six years ago my brother
married a very prog aggressive
[Laughter]
feminist oh when he quickly became a
beta exactly she he married an abusive
intolerant person that is going under
the heading of a progressive feminist
Progressive feminism has nothing to do
with turning the person you're with into
a a submissive person that's not not a
Rel this is right out of the gate this
sounds like an abusive relationship it's
just funny when a woman does it to a man
because it's not physical when a man
does it to a woman you know there's an
intimidation there's a physical thing
it's an ugly thing but when a woman does
it to a guy it's like a [__] mind
trick and
uh it's sad but not it's it's still
funny because he doesn't have any
bruises uh she made all the decisions
and he just let her
dominate I
mean I don't want to blame the victim
here but at some point you got to be
like lady [__] relax right all right
about two years ago my kid brother told
our family that he and his wife were
polyamorous and skirted around the fact
that it was kind of her
idea oh yeah no she's not she's not a
progressive feminist she's a [__]
psycho uh please tell me your brother
doesn't have money he explained it and
it just sounds like modern-day swingers
but the partners are often boyfriends
girlfriends who will often stay the
night or be around on
holidays they both got respectable jobs
and make decent money they both just
turned
30 I'm going to go out on a limb and say
this relationship isn't going to
last um if they weren't parents I
wouldn't give a [__] but their kids are
spending holidays with new girlfriends
and seeing their parents have friends
stay over with them no they're going to
[__] those kids up they're going to [__]
those kids up big time you
know get a babysitter all right go out
to some
[__] sleazy
Motel uh the kids are five and six years
old yeah they already they're already
[__] they're already [__] they
already know what's going on and we're
all kind of worried about how this will
affect the kids yet no matter who talks
to him he shrugs it off calls us prudes
and says monogamy is harming kids and
that his kids like his
girlfriends kids his kids like his
girlfriends and that his therapist says
this lifestyle isn't affecting the
kids uh yeah that's all a bunch of
[__]
um yeah that's that's terrible uh my
untrained opinion I think that's
[__] that is ridiculous it's just two
people being
selfish um this Thanksgiving we had his
new girlfriend over with others they go
on
dates there's sleepovers the wife and
his girlfriend get manicures together
strangely though yet he's pretty quiet
about what his wife does or her level of
involvement with
men how do we Vince him to cut the [__]
out stand up to his life leave her I
don't know do some do something bro or
are we all meddling in someone else's
relationship and should just butt
out um yeah that's what I would
do I feel like this is one of these
things that he's going to have to figure
it out for himself and the more you try
to lead him to water the more stubborn
he's going to be like if he's literally
looking at you when you're saying like
hey man you
know hey man like
maybe maybe you guys should get a
divorce you know if you really want to
like [__] other people here like if he's
like I don't know
like I mean I I think for you there's
just boundaries I would just be like
listen you can live your life any way
you want any way you want to live it I
don't want that around me or my kids
okay so I don't want I like I you
shouldn't be letting him bring his
[__] girlfriend over
all right like that's [__] ridiculous
like you I his life is his [__] life
and and hopefully he's going to come out
the other side and be like wow that
escalated quickly you know the Run
burgundy thing but if he doesn't like I
mean you you got to keep that [__] away
from your your world you don't want your
kids seeing that um live your life
however the [__] you want to live it but
like you know if that doesn't go with
how you're living then there's no reason
to have it in your house uh other than
that you know good luck to him I
mean I don't know what that is they just
seem like too selfish people who wanted
to have kids but just still wanted to be
out there they're too afraid to be
single or something I don't know what it
is
um like if you wanted to be with
somebody and that's what you guys did
and you didn't have kids I agree with
you I would be like all right I mean if
that's what you guys want to do cool but
once you have kids like that's when
stops being you time it's it's it's your
kids they're they're what's matters and
whatever the [__] is going on with you
is it's not even secondary it's like
[__] you know ranked 20th it's not
even in the top
um and
uh I don't know what strip mul therapist
they're going to but uh I there's no
[__]
way there's no [__] way that's
not
that is just you know and once they
really put it all
together you know it's bad enough
someday they're going to figure out
there's no Santa Claus and that that was
a lie but Jesus
Christ wow okay anyway land down
under hey Billy billiard head uh I'm in
need of some advice Play the song oh I I
don't have it at my I don't have it
anymore it's somewhere on my laptop it's
time for advice hey with your host Billy
Burr and I'm off this Melody from
somebody else uh okay I'm in need of
some advice uh about what to do with
this girl I met while
traveling uh Banger and forget about it
how far away does she
live all right for contexts I'm a
24-year-old Canadian guy who stepped
away from my job teaching High School to
travel the
world that's amazing I'm writing you
from Bangkok and I just finished a a
3-month trip in Eastern
Europe that's awesome what a time to do
it and you're
single amazing on that trip to Europe I
met the most amazing woman in one of my
hostals I always laugh at hosts cuz I
got stuck in one of those one times when
I did a gig in Chicago uh we traveled
together for over a month and we got
along really well she's beautiful and is
honestly the first woman I've met who I
can see my spell self spending the rest
of my life with what's the problem well
she's 33 and from the Outback of
Australia as someone who wants kids
being with her would basically mean
putting the traveling aside moving to
Australia and settling down immediately
all of my friends think I'm insane for
even considering this but I've never
felt this certain about a chick at the
same time I love traveling and don't
know if I'm 100% ready to settle down at
this moment uh then I wouldn't do it all
right I can't help how you feel about
this [__] woman but oh my God she's
the greatest I can really see myself
settling down but you know I don't know
[__] that you're not ready you're
24 don't do
it um I'll be traveling with her for
another month in Southeast Asia and I
have I have to decide if I'm heading
back home with her uh I keep on going
back and forth on what to do here and
any advice would be appreciated thanks
and go [__] yourself uh at the end of
this trip I wouldn't go to
Australia just tell her this is a huge
decision and I need to be 100% And I
just need some time to think about it
and if she doesn't like that she can go
down under I'm telling you dude like
uh you know there's always something
about a longdistance relationship where
you really let your guard down because
they're not all up in your grill they're
not right down the street it it doesn't
feel [__] real so it feels in this
[__] up way safe
to kind of Let Yourself Go and then like
you know you're traveling around you're
seeing the world that's a big difference
than in the middle living in the middle
of the [__] Outback and this is our
town and every day we go here for coffee
and over here we get a [__] veite
sandwich or whatever the [__] they do
down there that's a big
difference um but only you know what
your hot feels so from afar I
mean people are always writing and oh my
God I met the greatest guy I met the
greatest woman the only problem the the
person of last week they they live in
the [__]
Philippines of course you fell in love
with them there's no
risk and she's Filipino they're
gorgeous anyways thanks and go [__]
yourself PS I've been listening to your
podcast since I was 17 and just wanted
to thank you I know this will probably
make you all awkward but your
willingness to talk about therapy and
everything has has really helped me with
sorting through some of the [__]
from my past well that's great listen to
the pod on the road also helps me get a
taste of home while traveling all right
well good luck with that
sir um well look at that I already did a
[__] hour so I don't need to check
back in after the Bills game I'm GNA
watch the Bills game but I I got to do I
got to do a couple of reads here I got
to do a couple of reads
here um all right hyms everybody hey you
want to have a better sex uh better sex
but erectile dysfunction is getting in
the way I would argue that it's not
getting in the way it's just [__]
hanging there blowing in the breeze if
so you're not alone millions of men deal
with the hardships of
Ed all right the head of your dick has
got a full-on view of the south pole
rather than the North Pole pull the
Opposites there but with hyms there's a
simpler affordable way to get treated
for erectile dysfunction so you can get
your groove back in the bedroom and a at
a cost that you desire HS is changing
men's healthc Care by providing access
to Affordable and discreet Sexual Health
treatments all from the comfort of your
couch HS provides access to clinically
proven generic alternatives to Viagra
and Calis up to 95% cheaper with options
as low as $2 per dose uh the process is
simple and 100% online no uncomfort
doctor visits no insurance is needed pay
one low price for your treatments online
visits ongoing shipments and
provider uh messaging HS with hundreds
of thousands of trusted subscribers or
if erectile dysfunction is getting you
down it's time to change that start your
free online visit today at hs.com that's
HS Hotel India Mike sierra.com bur for
your personalized erectile dysfunction
treatment options him
/ur prescription require on an online
prescriptions require an online
consultation with the healthcare
provider who will determine if
appropriate restrictions apply see
websites for details and important
safety information subscription required
price varies based on product and
subscription plan oh look who it is
everybody in no
Cheeto it's time to start your style
Redemption story and look great at your
next big event upgrade that off theack
suit sitting in your closet with a fully
customized Perfect Fit suit from
indochino yeah the suits are cheap and
you're going to look great and if
somebody spills a drink on it you're not
going to give a [__] measure yourself in
10 minutes on a visit uh or visit a
showroom wear your new look right out of
the box and keep your budget
unbustable pockets and lapels customiz
uh custom clothing at a surprisingly
affordable price quality wools linen and
cotton in different colors and patterns
uh talk about how Indo Chino tells you
what is in style so you're not guessing
when you're choosing customizations I
didn't know they did that I'm glad they
did that CU I have no style whatsoever
my style is no style uh set up your
measurement profile in under 10 minutes
at home or make a showroom appointment
new colors fabrics and outer wear Styles
added regularly so it's easy to create
your next look dress better than the
other guys with indochino go to
indochino.com and use the code bur to
get 10% off any purchase of $3.99 a more
that's 10% off i n d o c io.com with the
code
Burr all right that is the podcast
everybody uh go [__] yourselves I'll
check in on you on Thursday I'm going to
go watch that uh that bills Chiefs game
uh like I said my money's on the Chiefs
but I'm for the bells
there